TIMOTHY JORDAN: Hello,
I'm Timothy Jordan,
and this is your update about
the coolest developer news
from Google in the last week.
The latest version of
the Android Wear SDK
is now available with
several watch-face-related
enhancements.
Details and screenshots
are on the post linked
in the description below.
TensorFlow 1.5 is now available.
Updates include Eager Execution
for TensorFlow, now available
as a preview, the
Developer preview
of TensorFlow Lite, built
in, GPU acceleration updates,
documentation site
updates, and more.
Further details and the install
command are on the post.
We're hosting another
Google Developer Day
at this year's Game Developers
Conference on Monday, March 19.
Join us for a few
sessions focused
on innovation and new platforms,
pre-launch best practices,
and strategies to improve
performance post-launch.
Sign-up links are on the post.
We're making it easier for
you to develop and publish
Gmail add-ons domain-wide to
give your users access to tools
directly in their inbox.
You can now publish
Gmail add-ons
to users in your G Suite
domain, install Gmail add-ons
for G Suite accounts before
they're published, and more.
Doc links are on the post.
The content on golang.org is
now available in mainland China
through golang.google.cn.
All of you who are a part
of the growing Go developer
community in China can
now directly access
official documentation,
technical articles,
and binaries.
Please remember to like,
subscribe, and share.
I'm Timothy Jordan, and
I'll see you next week.
Thanks for watching this week's
episode of The Developer Show.
If you'd like to catch
some of our prior episodes,
they're right over here.
[MUSIC PLAYING]